à conflans sainte honorine les élèves
ont repris ce mardi le chemin du collège
du bois d'aulne les jeunes ont été
accueillis par niveau tout au long de la
journée entre 8h et 16h un périmètre de
sécurité a été dressé par les forces de
l'ordre autour de l'établissement sur
place beaucoup d'émotion forcément
parents enfants et enseignants ont
toujours en tête l assassinat du
professeur d'histoire-géographie samuel
pâtit survenu le 16 octobre dernier et
des psychologues étaient présents pour
permettre à tous d'échanger et de mettre
des mots sur ce tragique événement
réaction de parents d'élèves qui a
accompagné ce matin leurs enfants au
collège c'était au micro de justin
brasier très compliqué très compliqué
j'ai je me cache pas j'ai une boule au
ventre
j'ai très peur aussi comme mes enfants
ils ont très peur mais j'essaie de pas
leur montrer ne pas leur communiquer ma
peur a malheureusement ils reprennent
l'école et ils vont vivre avec ça ils
vont vivre avec ça ils vont grandir avec
ça ils vont se construire avec ça je
croise pas c'est calme mais les forces
de l'ordre qui sont peu partout donc
c'est plutôt rassurant
et puis j'ai tendance à penser que ce
qui est arrivé une fois va pas se
reproduire au même endroit donc quelque
part voilà je suis plutôt plutôt
tranquille à ce niveau là après j'espère
que c'est plus les enfants j'espère
qu'ils vont pas trop perturbé par tout
ce qui se passe